foreign
Boys in today's day and age with the
internet and devices and all the things
how do you appropriately have the sex
talk and cover all of that and what's an
appropriate way to normalize discussions
about relationships and intimacy
[Music]
what is going on this is John with the
Dr John deloney show
literally the greatest mental health and
marriage parenting podcast ever exists
ever ever we talk about whatever's going
on in your life mental health challenges
you're struggling with or your family
members are struggling with how to be a
better parent how to be a better spouse
or how to figure out what in the world's
going on in your relationship whatever's
going on your world I'm going to walk
alongside you and we're gonna figure it
out I mean I know the answers but I
promise I'll tell you the truth and I
might refer you out and tell you to go
talk to somebody else but we will figure
this thing out if you want to be on this
show go to John deloney.com
ask ask on the internet and just fill
out the form and it goes to Kelly and
Jenna and actually if you fill it out
today Jenna will not be paying attention
because this is the week of the Taylor
Swift shows both of them
oh my God I already got my merch on I'm
ready
how do you pre-buy merch that's the most
Millennial thing I've ever heard I mean
they had a whole truck set up I just had
Chris went down for me he said text me
said hey what you want and I said I know
exactly what I want and he got it you
told him what you wanted what you really
really wanted I did I did and I really
really got it wearing it today that's a
husband right there
that's not no he's not my husband
what's your husband's name Reed this is
Chris Chris Wright oh your boss yeah I
told him the merch truck was there and
he said oh I'm gonna go down after work
I told him I couldn't go and so he said
he's a massive yeah t-swift fan this is
one of the guys from your band he's in
done be very clear about that I did not
know he was a Swifty oh he's a full-on
Swifty he's going Sunday night
we may have to reach the intervention
for sure yeah we need to circle the
wagons on this guy wow Kelly though will
be there to answer your phone call
because she does not believe in Joy or
concerts so that'll be great that'll be
good
um or happiness so she will be willing
to take your emails hey and don't forget
to hit the Subscribe button or the like
button and
Ben I like t-swift too I can't lie man
she's good man I was strong of you to to
say that this is a show about
vulnerability and telling the truth
she's good man she's real real good she
is it's annoying how good she is
especially when I'm middling at my job
all right let's go to Jason in Colorado
Springs what's up brother Jason
oh you know just partying over here yes
it's kind of early to be partying in
Colorado Springs but that's all good so
what's up dude yeah that's all right
well I wanted to get your opinion I'm uh
I'm the dad of two boys one just turned
13. and so this is kind of like a
two-parter um I'm kind of wondering in
today's day and age with the internet
and devices and all the things how do
you appropriately have the sex talk and
cover all of that and kind of tagging on
to that what's an appropriate way to
normalize discussions about
relationships and intimacy
it's a great question man
um
can I can I beat you up but not because
I don't like you but just because it
will send a message to all the other
parents is that cool
yeah absolutely because I'm sure I'm not
the only one thinking these things no I
know I know you're not so I'm really
grateful that you called so I think to
start out number one 13 is way too late
probably by seven or eight years
okay okay
um
I think the days uh well let's just
let's just be honest the sex talk as a
singular event is an utter failure
it doesn't work it never has worked it
didn't work for you and me it didn't
work for anyone we know nobody walked
out of the sex talk and they're like oh
hell yeah now I know how to do this and
my dad's awesome and he'll always be a
safe place to go talk about girls I mean
like that that has never happened in
human history ever
it has just been like wow I will I will
never talk to them about anything ever
again because all of my body hurts after
that call right you know what I'm saying
so and honestly that that's part of my
second part of that question is because
when I got that talk my dad wouldn't
even do it my grandpa had a couple gin
and tonics and asked me if I knew how to
put on a condom
I didn't want to talk about any of that
with anyone ever again that's one of the
best sex talks I've ever heard right
there that's that's yeah right and
correct I mean inside it all figured out
and uh but I just want something better
for these kids you know yeah so I I I
think
ultimately the sex talk that idea comes
from a faulty notion and it's about sex
it's about
um anger and rage it even bleeds over
into the conversation about suicide
if we bring it up
that it's going to suddenly give our
kids insights into something that they
didn't know exists and that's not true
because their bodies exist
and so what our silence does or what our
when we turn beat red in our face we're
like or we get all nervous or when a kid
asks us something innocent when they're
six or nine or ten or four and our eyes
start darting around the room looking
for our spouse or whatever they absorb
all of that
and so the greatest thing parents can do
is just to Norm sex to Norm bodies
because it should be happening inside
their house right so it's uh it's
what's going to change is the details
and degrees right I am never going to go
into gruesome detail with about me and
my wife like into you know what I mean
that's not appropriate my my son will be
in more therapy than he's already going
to be in but the other day my daughter's
seven and I dude I'm just
let me tell you the rules of my house
number one every conversation is on the
table a hundred percent all the time
there is nothing in our house that we
won't talk about or discuss and so
that's just an ethos right and that can
be about religion that can be about
political topics that can be about
anything
we also don't gossip so we don't talk
crap about other people so my kids know
that it's not a free-for-all and the
rule that my wife and I have is any
question that gets asked whoever gets
asked answers it so there's not a big
there's not a big um production there's
not a big it's like confetti falling
from the sky in the big talk right
um what it is is like the other day my
I'm literally just I'm doing something
in the kitchen and my daughter's sitting
there at the at the counter she's seven
and she just says Hey Dad I just don't
understand this and I was like what what
do you understand baby
dude it could have been I don't
understand how wolf dragons are create
fire I mean it could have been any
number of things coming out of her mouth
and she said I just don't understand how
your part gets into Mommy to make me and
I just started laughing I was like I
guess we're doing this right now right
and my wife walks by and she has a huge
grin on her face because she knows the
rules She Walks Behind my daughter and
just keeps on walking it's not a weird
thing in our house
and it ended with yes we are naked and
my daughter goes oh
no but it wasn't a there was nothing
weird about it you see what I'm saying
last night when I was carrying my
daughter to bed and we were hanging out
in my room I was carrying her to bed and
I said hey when we walk by I want you to
kick mom like we're just being silly and
she goes no and I put her foot by my
wife's shoulder and my wife leaned over
and kissed her on the top of the foot
and I whispered to my daughter
I will never kiss her again and my
daughter starts dying laughing right so
that's just an ethos in our house now we
are silly and goofy not every family is
like that and that's okay but I think
the greatest conversation is asking
questions all like just how constantly
asking questions constantly you and your
wife talking about it not in a gruesome
or gross way or uh making light of it
but just the kids are going to absorb
what's okay to talk about and what's not
okay to talk about okay the second thing
is
um my parents your parents they got to
play defense
they got to just try to keep Playboys
out of the house
right they got to keep try to keep like
uh HBO out of the house
those days are long gone they're over
and so I don't allow my kids to have
phones and I know I'm weighing the
minority on that and I'm a hundred
percent confident not even a shadow of a
doubt in my life that the Arc of
um the next 10 to 15 years that I'll be
proven correct on that deal but I just
don't allow it
um and then when your kids get older and
you decide to hand them a phone you have
to know I'm handing them over
to every Playboy ever in the human
history is right on their phone every
pornography app every video ever
recorded is on that phone
and
please don't make videos of your own
please don't ask people for photos of
your own because now you're trafficking
child support so I think you have those
conversations very very directly but
listen those conversations have to be
set up early
right so I have a hard conversation with
my son at 12 because his stupid school
just hands them Chromebooks and I tell
them about hey if you put something in
an email to your friends
it will be there for eternity
and I told him about a joke that I
thought was really funny when I was a
kid and how utterly disgusting and
offensive it is now that I know better
and so I I went first leading with
here's what I've done wrong thank God
it's not in writing
and so I start the conversation there so
that in three or four years
I can tell them hey
somebody's gonna send you a picture
of them without a shirt on
please please delete that immediately
and let me know let your mom know and so
I'm trying to set up that so that when I
say hey we need to have a talk it's not
he doesn't his body isn't going to fight
or flight he just knows dad has these
kind of talks with me because he we're
open in the house does that make sense
it does and I I will say if those are
the kind of talks we have had because we
did give him a device and you know we
laid those out pretty pretty frankly
okay if you've got a 13 year old advice
you better have 100 Access to every
every
every keystroke on that thing
absolutely and know that they can get
around it because they're smart right
and the same way you and I got exactly
our parents rules but man yeah
um I mean like there's some apps out
there that every text he gets you get
every website he goes to you go I would
have every nook and cranny that thing
covered and again it's because we're
handing
I mean we're handing a device to a child
that can ruin their professional life
that's such an extraordinary
responsibility that we're putting in
their hands they can send the wrong text
they can ask I mean and they're 15. of
course they're going to ask somebody to
send a picture I mean they're 15.
I'm not gonna blame a kid for wanting to
see
um somebody the opposite sex naked
they're they're 16 they're 19. oh I
would never like that's not on them
that's on us we're adults right and so I
mean I would have those conversations
regularly
um and and I yeah I'm just making a part
of life and conversation
yeah
um what in your house in your house
where does it get awkward
it
gets awkward in
him getting to getting him engaged in
any of those conversations and I I
understand it because this kid is a
carbon copy of me I mean
I I yeah I know what's going through his
brain right because he's just me just
younger and he's gone from the last
couple years you know from like a pudgy
short kid to all of a sudden just
exploded into you know
a full a full teenager in a man-sized
body you know I know what's going
through his brain and he doesn't want to
talk about any of it he doesn't want to
he won't even I mean we can go to a
school function he gets plenty of smiles
from the girls and stuff and if we try
to even talk about that he just does not
want to talk about it one bit right so I
think a going first
and hearing you talk about it
so maybe the next time your wife walks
through quietly whisper to him
my God she's beautiful
um and it could never be gratuitous and
never be gross never be like oh man I
can't wait till no that's inappropriate
for parents and kids but letting him
hear you honor how beautiful your wife
is
yeah
asking him hey I'm gonna do something
really nice for her like what do you
think she'd be into and what you're
doing is you're teaching him to keep his
eyes open
right so it's a it's a broader
conversation than just doing it
it's a broader conversation than just
like bras and under I mean the whole
thing is a broader conversation and
keeping your eyes open and what is
dignity what does respect look like all
those things
most of the time
the awkwardness that kids absorb and
experience is reflected somehow in their
parents
yeah and I can't tell you I cannot
describe to you
the millions and millions and millions
of moms and dads who see each other
naked
and have sex
and have babies
and cannot talk about sex amongst
between the two of them
I can't talk about what they're into
what they want to try what they are
awkward about like and it just permeates
the house you know what I mean
and so there's something to be said for
couples if you're gonna raise kids
you'll have to be able to talk about sex
because if you all can't talk about it
God help your poor kids
right and they just grow it's kind of
like if you have one um in-law who's a
little bit out to lunch right and
if you bring it up like one of y'all
gets really touchy about it and just the
kids just learn don't talk about
Granddad because whoa mom gets fired up
yeah it's very similar with sex
if you can't talk about it behind closed
doors your kids are NE they're gonna
know it's not okay
are there things that you and your wife
can't talk about or that are weird or
awkward or make you blush
um I not really but also not
there are we talk about pretty much
anything but behind closed doors right
like we're not we're not talking about
there's a lot of things that her and I
just talk about together privately okay
not and it should be that way it should
be that way it shouldn't be like hey
honey you want to try this like at the
at the dinner table that would no don't
do that right right but I mean probably
the whole you know the full extent of
any of those conversations happens just
between the two of us and never never in
front of the kids there you go so I
think there's something about
um being intentional about holding your
wife's hand
being intentional about hugging every
morning being intentional about kissing
your wife in front of your kids
yeah um letting your kids see that
you're a sexual being without being
pervy McGee
yeah right and
um I I'm I
I know my kids my son's old enough now
that his kids his friends listen to this
show sometimes and give him crap about
it so I don't want to embarrass him but
I I
I don't really give him an option like
I'll tell them hey we're gonna talk
about this
all right I need the update man he's
like dude I think nope I need the update
man and so we're pretty open about it
pretty open okay and um I also want him
to have other men in his life that I
dude I'm his dad I know it's always
going to be weird
um but I want him to have men in his
life that he can talk to also
um so whether that's a coach
um whether that's one of his buddies
dads
um
whether that's a minister or somebody
that he trusts from local church
whatever that is
um that he's got people in his life that
he can talk to and I'm that for several
of my buddies um kids they can call
Uncle John and ask him all kind of weird
stuff and they know I'm gonna tell I'll
be able to answer him and I'm not going
to turn all beat red
um and I'll ask them you know for help
with Finance or help with you know if my
kid wants to go to trade school or
something I'll call you know junking so
anyway all that to say is this don't
make it this singular event
um and by the way I do believe in events
for 13 year olds I think that's an
important thing but it's a total event
like you're becoming a man now you're
becoming a woman now like you are
transitioning I think that whole thing
is incredible
but that can't be the sex talk with a
period at the end of it talking about
sex talking about body parts talking
about you're nothing is wrong with your
body anything is not one thing is gross
about your body not one thing you should
be ashamed of about your body
um some things are private some things
are not for the world and there's some
great books about that some great
children's books to talk about private
parts and like behind bathing suit Parts
things like that it's great man but
those need to be constant conversations
that start really really young and just
are integrated into the household so
that kids never feel ashamed of
themselves and they never think that sex
is some
great that's just not some mysterious
crazy thing it's just this amazing rad
awesome thing especially inside of a
context and um it's awesome so good for
you for being a great dad man keep
loving your kid and just start the
regular conversation and when he doesn't
want to be a part of it he's he's 13. of
course he doesn't want to be a part of
it
it's your job to bridge that Gap
um and to let him know that it's is he
safe and it's comfortable and it's all
good and um
that you think his mom is beautiful too
we'll be right back
[Music]
this show is sponsored by better help
folks take a minute to think about how
much time you spend on yourself it's
easy to get caught up in what people
need from you and want from you and
never think about what you need and then
you end up too stretched out burned out
all of the madness of our current world
resting on your shoulders
look sometimes I put my head down to
work and then realize I haven't had a
meaningful conversation with my wife and
kids all day I get focused on what I'm
doing and I'm running and running and
running
and I don't know how to come back and
therapy is a great way to learn new
skills that make you the best version of
yourself they help you set boundaries
and still have energy left to help
others without leaving yourself behind
so if you're thinking of starting
therapy give better help a try it's
totally online to fit into your schedule
you just fill out a brief questionnaire
to get matched with a licensed therapist
and you can switch therapists at any
time for no additional charge so find
more balance find Wellness with better
help visit betterhelp.com deloney today
to get 10 off your first month that's a
better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right we are back let's go out to
Nicole in Orlando what's up Nicole
hey Dr John what up
uh not much how you doing partying
partying you
um I'm trying not to freak out because I
usually only talk to you like in my head
and now I'm actually talking to you now
it's like for real promise I'm way
smarter in your head than I am in real
life way way smarter yeah that's why it
usually works what's up
um yeah so I was calling because I'm
really struggling on making a decision
about if I should stay in my marriage
um just for my son
um no you know
I don't even know what the answer is
but no
why do you want to leave your marriage
actually the way you just asked that
question why do you need to leave your
marriage
um
we got married
um he comes from a you know religious
background where it was like either you
know
um break up and not be together or get
married so we got married which you know
we were dating for a while but I don't
think I would have ever married them it
wasn't because of that
um but you did so here you are yeah yeah
you've got all this and we've got all
this background stuff that's it just is
what it is you all are here now why
isn't it not working now
well the first time it wasn't working
was just because you know we kind of
decided that we were going to call it um
you know getting to know each other
better being married you know we were
both really unhappy he doesn't celebrate
holidays because of his religion and you
know that was very stressful but when
pandemic happened we never I never want
to like actually leaving and you know
essentially got together
and then as I was like really kind of
trying I found out that he was sleeping
with the neighbor so you know it broke
my heart and um
when I kind of I guess kind of got open
over the brokenheartedness about it then
I was obviously like angry
and you know I asked myself the first
time we were deciding to split up like I
was okay with it I don't know if it's
because my son was more like you know a
baby couldn't even talk yet now he's
five
and I just feel like I can't picture a
single day going by where I don't wake
up and and he's there
can I just be real direct with you
Nicole
okay this isn't about your son man
I get that you you can't imagine your
life with with like for a second I get
that too 100 like I I
um I am unnerved by how much I love
being around my kids okay almost I have
to right I I it's strange for me I get
that
but this isn't about your kid and I
don't want you to make decisions right
now with through that lens because
you're gonna end up if you leave
and some of this the the data tells me
that your net worth will go down your
life will get harder
for a season especially
that all like if you don't get I don't
want you to blame a five-year-old for
that
or if you stay I don't want him to be
the reason that you're miserable and
unhappy and that's the position you've
placed this five-year-old in
so I know you want to see him every day
you love him more than life itself all
that is incredible
you have to make an adult decision about
an adult relationship
and he can't be the glasses that you are
wearing to make that decision
I mean I've been
wrong and it's just like I I totally
understand what you're saying but like
you know there's other people that I see
that that do this all the time and I
feel like for some reason like I I can't
like handle it like it's it's all about
my son like I I feel like I would put up
with like you know basically like a
marriage to just sorry excuse my
language um you could just be to be you
know with him all the time like you know
listen if you do that that's this that's
an incredibly selfish thing
because you are teaching him you're
using him as a pacifier
you're using him for you to feel better
and in the process you're like you're
using him like a blanket
and in the process you're teaching him
this is what love looks like
this is what women deserve
this is what dads do this is what
husbands do
and you're just putting cinder blocks in
his backpack that he's gonna have to
spend his whole life unwinding
yeah that was kind of what I was afraid
of it is if you don't want if your
husband cheats on you with your neighbor
and you don't want to be married to him
anymore
don't be married to him anymore
but be an adult and you make an adult
decision and live with the consequences
of that decision because you've already
made the decision to get married to the
guy
and you can't blame anybody you can't
blame his religion you can't blame you
chose that
and if you choose to stay with somebody
who cheated on you great y'all figure it
out
that happens all the time and people
rebuild their relationship completely
anew
and they come up with something that was
stronger and more magnificent I don't
want to say more magnificent like good
thing that's happened but man it
re-contextualizes what I'm worth and
what I value in the what I will and
won't put up with it just changes
everything
and you get to pick that
but you're choosing misery in a
relationship right now and I just and
you're and you're making it your
five-year-old's fault and I just don't
think that's that's fair to him
yeah
what makes you think that your husband
cheats on you what makes you think
um that you're gonna have to split
custody
um well I know that the
law in Florida is it's a 50 50
the 50 50 state so okay
yeah will he fight you for custody
he wouldn't fight me I think he would be
pretty agreeable to being you know
in the world if I could just have him
and go I would have done that but I know
I have to share so have you asked your
husband that
uh yeah and he said no way
yeah of course I mean we're super in
love with him
so what keeps you and your husband from
going away for a weekend and figuring
this thing out
I mean
um I'm not not totally sure on that you
know I mean the the reasons why we kind
of decided to not be together in the
first place you know obviously like all
these are kind of a big deal we don't
really have the same kind of belief
um
is your husband willing to lose his
marriage over these these
things like holidays and stuff
I don't know
here's what it sounds like to me sounds
like you got two people who are kind of
dug in
but they've been it's almost like World
War One like they're they're entrenched
in a position and the people fighting
don't even really know what we're
fighting
and you start creating stories about the
person on the other side that you're
fighting not realizing that y'all are
way more similar than you are apart
usually not always
usually in this kind of situation
one of y'all is desperate for the other
person to flip the lights on and turn
the music off and say what are we doing
because if there was no smoke left in
this relationship at all not one spark I
think you would have laughed
are you are you able to tell me this
thing is done dead and over or if he was
to sit down with you and say hey I love
you
man it's been a rocky go
we got in a rocket ship that we didn't
even know we were doing but here we are
I want to make this thing work would you
be all in or would you be like not too
bad you slept with the neighbor
um there's no judgment there's no
judgment either way yeah I'm just trying
to build a context here yeah yeah
it's kind of where I find myself now is
like do I make that decision to be all
in or not to be all in and you know my
list is my son so you know if there's
any risk of losing him then I feel like
I should say but then if I'm only
staying because of him then you know
it's a lot harder to think of why I
would stay
I want you to do some soul searching
not about your son you know where you
stand there
but it feels like you got hurt bad
and you are scared to get hurt ever
again
and so you're gonna you're going to go
to the beach like wrapped up in a huge
blanket so you can get no sun on you
because one time you got burned and what
you're going to do in the process is
Miss the entire trip to the beach
you're gonna miss your whole life
yeah the only way your marriage works
moving forward is if you're willing to
get hurt again
and I hate that about relationships but
it's just the truth all relationships
are a risk 100 of them
the one way you can mitigate that risk
is you take the lead and I think your
whole life you have been
just being led around by the nose Fair
yeah
doing what everybody else in your life
wanted you to do
and I'd love you to take the lead and
take this guy out if if you're in and
now I'm pushing you one way
um
because that's the way I feel like we're
going on the phone I could be way out to
lunch so don't just do this because I'm
saying to okay
but I'd love to see you sit take him out
somewhere
and get a babysitter and look at him and
say
I'm not done with this thing
everything's got to change all of it
me you what I'll accept boundaries all
of it but let's put it on the table and
either we're going to both be all in or
we both got to figure out what being out
means
but this halfway thing is killing you
it's killing your husband and it's
destroying your son
yeah is that fair
yeah yeah I've never really thought
about like I thought about having a
conversation with him but I never really
thought about actually telling him
what I want for the future if that's
even possible lay it out there lay it
out there because the worst you can say
is no and then you get your answer
yeah and then you gotta grieve your
marriage and you got to figure out what
divorce looks like and all the hell that
that is
but there is a chance he says oh my God
thank God
and I want you to have written down
spent some time you may need to go see a
counselor spend some time or get with a
couple of your friends that you trust
deeply here's what I need moving forward
and that can be everything from you
gotta get off your stupid phone to I'm
gonna have to go through a rebuilding
season
where I'm going to learn to trust you
again because you were banging the
neighbor while I was trying to keep our
house together right I want you to lay
down all these things that you need
these things that you want
and then he's gonna have his list too
and you've probably been pretty cold the
last few years Fair
oh definitely okay so let's figure out
what this thing's gonna look like lay
all these things out and say can you
live with this can I live with this
and it may be a disaster but at least
you have an answer at least you're not
living halfway one foot in one foot out
because everybody's getting hurt this
way is that fair
yeah definitely will you do me a huge
favor will you let me know how that
conversation goes
and let me tell you this if you show up
to this conversation and just start
throwing grenades he's Gotta Fight You
Back
go to that conversation and say here is
what I need
and here's what I want I want to go all
in
all in or if you spend some time
thinking about this writing your needs
down and you realize I am done I'm done
done done then take him out and say I'm
done
we need to figure out what this is going
to look like
and I'd love to see if you'll be okay
with weekends instead of weekday
whatever but we can figure something out
the it works for both of you
um
well let's stop living halfway
all all in
and risk getting hurt again
I'll go ahead and say it he'll hurt you
again he'll say something stupid he'll
do something dumb you'll hurt him you'll
say something stupid you'll do something
dumb
that's marriage and then it's gonna be
about are we willing to repair are we
willing to go back into the cycle again
let me know how this goes
I actually have really high hopes for
y'all
this could take somebody being a
grown-up
maybe that can be you we'll be right
back
all right we're back and uh here we go
again it's facts are your friends let's
do it
oh geez all right today we are talking
about how to find a therapist
how to find a therapist we've talked
about this on the show before and it
continues to be one of the most
um common questions we get how do I find
a counselor how to find a therapist how
to find a social worker what's the
difference all that kind of stuff okay
so we're going to talk about how to find
the right therapist I'm going to give
you a couple of bullet points here that
you can follow
um pull out a pen and a paper write this
stuff down
um so here we go number one I want to
Define what they are and what they are
not okay so when you think of mental
health professional
you can start with your local doctor and
your doctor your regular doctor your
primary care physician is going to get a
couple of classes on Mental Health stuff
on psychiatric stuff
um they're not gonna usually get
questions
classes on how to deal with trauma in
fact almost never on how to sit with
somebody over the long a long period of
time
um I will tell you the first time I went
to go get help I went and met with a
medical doctor but he was a buddy so I
had a relationship with him and remember
the word relationship because that's
going to be really important
a psychiatrist is a medical doctor okay
that's a medical doctor who goes to med
school and then goes on to specialize in
psychiatric care mental health issues
I'm sad to say that most Psychiatry
nowadays is entirely medicine based it's
it's entirely biological very few
classes if any on therapy on sitting
with somebody it's all moved to manage
care get you in hear your your X number
of symptoms give you a diagnosis at ic10
codes or out of the DSM and then get you
on get you meds and get you out of here
okay
um Psychiatry I think can be used great
as an adjunct to counseling care and
most of the research suggests that you
need to have that medicine works in
conjunction with
um counseling some sort of talk therapy
or some sort of Action Therapy but
that's where some people start okay some
people start there
a psychologist a psychologist
is the next rung if you only hierarchy
so if you look at mental health
professionals there's a hierarchy there
whether we want there to be one or not
and it's psychiatrists which are medical
doctors and then there's a psychologist
psychologists go get a graduate degree
you got to have a PhD or a psyd to to be
called a clinical psychologist and they
are trained usually from research more
research based they've got to do
research they have to do studies they're
going to be more clinical in their
approach
um more typologies this and again I'm
speaking broadly and generally beneath
that depending on which state you are in
it might be counselor it might be a
marriage and family therapist it might
be a social worker clinical licensed
clinical social worker and they're
social workers that are licensed to sit
with people they can do diagnosis they
can refer you out to psychiatrist and
then there's social workers that are to
help you navigate complex systems like a
medical system or the legal system or
whatever
so I'm talking about licensed clinical
social workers
at the end of the day
the research tells me that the most
important thing is not the modality not
the degree
of a licensed mental health professional
it's the Rapport between
the patient the client and the mental
health professional
how you feel interacting with this
person now I was thinking about this
when I was writing these notes out for
this
two of the most amazing therapists that
I refer to a lot
whose wisdom guides a lot of what I do
or Este perel and Terry reel Terence
real neither of them have phds neither
of them are doctor parel or doctor
um real
and they're amazing
my therapist the person I go to I know
they don't have a PhD I know they're not
a doctor so and so and I don't know what
their clinical licensure is in I
actually don't know
I know they're one of the most respected
and extraordinary counselors in the
United States and I was really fortunate
that she would take me on
um but I don't even know what her
clinical licensure is That's how little
I care about that kind of crap also
Gabor mate who you hear me talk about a
lot he's a medical doctor not a
psychiatrist but a medical doctor so all
that to say is and I have two phds and
I'm seeing somebody who's not a PhD all
that I want you to me say I don't care
it's about when you meet with this
person do you click
and here's how I know if like if I click
can I or will I tell this person the
truth
most of us have an innate sense that
this person in front of us is not safe
or they are safe doesn't mean it's not
going to be uncomfortable it's not going
to be weird
but can I tell them the truth
will I tell them the truth
if you sit down in front of somebody and
your guard immutably goes up you are not
you're wasting your time you're wasting
their time you're wasting your money
because if you're not going to tell the
truth and they can't help you it's like
going to the doctor and not telling them
that your foot is really really hurting
and instead telling me you got a
headache it's not going to help they're
never gonna get you the x-rays that you
need to get your your care okay so the
most important thing is the relationship
with your therapist can you tell the
truth if you need meds if you think you
need meds you can start anywhere with
any of these folks and they will let you
know
we've tried some things for a few weeks
I think it's best to refer you out to
your doctor or to a psychiatrist and
they will have lists of people they can
refer you out to okay so oh and one one
more quick side note here
life coaches
um Here's my thought on life coaches I
actually have one of those too and I
know that that's a lot I've got a life
coach and having a therapist
I don't go to my life coach the person I
sit with his name is Justin McRoberts
he's amazing
I don't go to him with
childhood traumas I don't go to him with
really deep structural marriage issues
with my wife and I are struggling I
don't go to him with like parenting
challenges I go to him when I have a
specific problem that I need to solve
that I'm struggling with like my
calendar like feeling sensitive all the
time when people give me feedback at
work like when I've got four or five
people at work all tell me the same
thing but I think I'm right he provides
a mirror for me and is able to say
things more directly often than a
counselor will that's what a coach is
coaches give you advice not always but
more so than a therapist will
um
I am technically not licensed I
intentionally did not get licensed in
the state of Tennessee
um because I didn't want to spend my
whole career fighting grenades that
people are throwing for licensure so
uh life coaches can get certified in
their particular thing but not all of
them have licenses and stuff it's great
I take specific and issues like
boundaries work challenges etc for life
coaching so if you're working through
like a particular issue call Life
Coachman it's easier to get in sometimes
um they can be less expensive sometimes
depending on who you call sometimes they
can be extraordinarily expensive
um but I don't have a problem at all in
fact I employ one and if you want to
check out Justin McRoberts he's the guy
that I re I work with and he's amazing
he's out of California and we do it
virtually and it's awesome
um all right so how to find the right
therapist all right number one I hate
that I have to start here but this is
the world we're in right now
I hate that I have to start here
figure out your finances
um usually it's going to be between 75
bucks and 250 bucks an hour sometimes a
little bit less if they're on a sliding
scale sometimes more sliding scale
simply means you're a teacher you make
forty two thousand dollars a year and
they are going to slide their rates down
and make you you will pay less than
somebody who makes a hundred thousand
dollars a year might have to pay full
full Freight great I'm a hundred percent
on board with sliding skill stuff okay
psychiatrists can be considerably more
expensive four or five hundred bucks an
hour sometimes testing is thousands of
dollars
um it just depends on what you need if
you've got cash pay many many many many
therapists have moved to cash pay
usually because their books are full
they don't have to deal with insurance
they can just say hey I cost 150 bucks
an hour people write them a check and
they'll move on
if you can afford to do that great
that's where I would start
um one side note you can pay with cash
and you can say like I do with my
counselors
I do not want any diagnosis in any
records so they don't and I'm paying
with cash if you have insurance if you
are going through your insurance often
insurance will require a diagnosis to
reimburse the therapist so they have to
put something down
um so if you got cash pay start there if
you need to run it through Insurance
great my wife has done that no big deal
at all no big deal at all run it through
insurance and you can often find a list
of practitioners in your area okay now
finding practitioners is hard
there is a shortage Nationwide it just
is
that's not an excuse to give up if you
need to talk to somebody okay it's not
an excuse
you need to know how much things will
cost before you go and by the way no
therapist should be upselling you things
or giving you packages on things or that
should never happen okay that should
never ever happen
and a therapist's job
should be to work themselves out of a
job with you their job is not to counsel
you for eternity
their job is to help you in the healing
process to walk alongside you okay if
you are struggling to find somebody a
group and I know they sponsor the show
so there you go but better help has been
extraordinary
um to folks who were just who were
peripheral to the Nashville shooting
that's who I referred them to got him a
code for better help okay so I have full
trust there I refer people that I care
about and love to better help no problem
at all and their promise is they will
see you within 24-48 hours okay dealing
with deep trauma online therapy or
talking on the phone therapy might not
be the best long term but man it's a
great place to get you going okay so
number two
after you dealt with the finances what
you can afford how are you going to work
that thing have an idea as to what you
want to talk about
have some sort of Direction okay I'm
ready to stop being so angry I want to
be a more present mom I want to be a
better dad than my dad I don't even know
where to start I just keep crying all
the time
everyone around me is telling me that
I'm depressed I keep asking if I'm
depressed I don't think I am
but it's time for me to talk to somebody
get a different a third party who's
who's neutral in this deal okay
more than likely you're gonna be wrong
and what you think is going on
I can't tell you the number of times
I've gone in and been like hey I need to
talk about X and within an hour we are
not talking about X we are talking about
why X is simply a symptom of why an a b
and c and d and e and f and g right but
have some sort of direction if you plop
down on the couch and you look at the
therapist and say fix me it's not going
to work good therapists can work with
that because they're good but man it
really helps to sit down and say I'm
ready to stop hurting
I am in the last stages of my life and I
want to have as much joy as possible I
just lost somebody that that means that
was my heartbeat and I can't breathe can
you help me with the grief and and so
have some sort of Direction there okay
um and I want to reiterate this you got
to tell the truth
you gotta tell the truth they teach us
in counseling 101 classes your clients
will lie to you your clients will lie to
you don't lie if you're gonna go and
you're gonna pay the money tell the
truth I slept with this many people I
hooked up with my bosses
um uh secretary and it's going to blow
my marriage up I hit my kid go tell the
truth okay
um all right number uh three where
should you look okay
number one check the internet in your
local area that's the easiest way okay
and there are waiting lists all over the
country get on them get on the waiting
list
just like your Barber who books four
months out or three months or whatever
get on the waiting list you never know
when you're gonna get a call okay so
number one get on a waiting list if four
or five or six people are like dude you
gotta go see Jenna you gotta go see
Jenna you got to go see Jenna and you
call Jenna and says hey I might take any
clients now but I got a waiting list get
on it go ahead and get on it why not
right why not but don't stop there
um after you've checked your local uh
internet uh if you check the local the
internet in your local area
ask friends families or co-workers
listen you are worth being well so
unless you're an abusive situation or
somebody that's going to take advantage
of you for for finding out that you're
going to a counselor
I let folks know
I see somebody and I got a coach my wife
sees somebody we will see somebody
together
ah it's fine it's great it's healthy
it's good most of the people I know
um who do hard things and have have hard
things in their past need to go do the
work they need to do the work okay let
people know more often than not somebody
will be like hey you should go see my
person they're great okay
also if you live in a community with a
with a local University call and find
out in West Texas where I just was
um the local University there was a
counseling program an Addiction
Counseling program a marriage and family
therapy program a psychology program the
medical school has a counseling program
all of them have things called clinics
the clinics are where graduate students
see clients for free or for very very
reduced rates and before you go I'm not
seeing no student I was a student
I was a student that's where I saw
clients
and so my colleagues were great it's a
great place to go and if you go see a a
graduate student
you're getting the benefit of not only
the graduate student but of often one or
two professors
so people with extensive experience and
so sometimes you get a benefit of two or
three therapists for the price of a
quarter of one right it can be an
amazing resource so if you live in a
local community check out the Clinics of
the mental health programs at the local
University it's a great
um way to get in and see somebody
um and you can also provide feedback
it's just awesome
um there's also local family counseling
services that are designed for folks who
have no money or very very little money
it's where I did my one of my
internships my practicums and I loved it
I loved it
um there's a great place to meet folks
all over the the Spectrum who are
struggling with things and also people
who had plenty of money that I got to
help so check out local family
counseling services or counseling
resources in your area as well and then
also there's church services
I do have a bias
I do have a bias and so it's just this
is just me
um there are good well-meaning uh
ministers that are not trained
that will often talk to folks
and unfortunately I've I've had a career
of people coming to me and being like
hey man I wouldn't sell my pastor and
they said X and Y Z and I just go oh my
gosh I cannot believe they said that
so I do have a bias against sprinting
out that way
I implore you if you're a pastor or a
minister you have to know when you're
over your head
you have to not look at people and say
well if you just prayed harder
or Jesus tells you don't be anxious so
uh
that's not helpful and in fact that
hurts people don't be that Pastor don't
be that Minister there's tons of
pastoral counselor training that you can
go get that will make you incredibly
effective and I hope that everyone who
has the
um the courage
to sit with somebody who's hurting we'll
go through the proper training there
okay so
that's basically oh here's the other one
call better help man call online service
they will get you in within 24-48 hours
if you're just stuck
again it's not often you're not going to
do this forever and ever and ever amen
but man it can be a great resource
when you finally get the courage up to
say okay I'm going I'm going last thing
I want to I want to pass along here
go
uh three times three to four times
before you decide to switch a therapist
okay
the first time should be a nervous vomit
session
you get it all out
this happened and this happened and this
happened and there's a thing that you're
like I don't want to say I don't say it
and you say it or you don't say it
that's the first session the second one
is awkward it's the second date you're
going back
you feel a little bit better because you
finally spoke out loud some of this crap
that you've been carrying around you
finally said my husband sucks I don't
know what to do I'm sick of my kids not
liking me
that's just that's that's the that's the
that's the forward to the book you
didn't started the book yet the work
comes so what are we gonna do now
okay second session is usually context
tell me how you grew up tell me about
your past tell me how long you've been
married how did you meet why all that
kind of digging into stuff it's
uncomfortable it doesn't feel like
you're getting anywhere you're building
relationship with the council you're
practicing saying your needs out loud
you're practicing telling the truth out
loud
session three is when things get hard
usually
that's when you start getting more
homework assignments you may get like a
timeline assignment or something like
that like put in the timeline here or I
want you to write down your listing you
might get some of that stuff in the
first couple sessions session three
session four is when you start doing the
work
we're gonna learn some breathing
exercises because we got to talk about
some hard stuff
we are going to
practice going to the gym three times
whatever the thing might be that you and
your therapist are working through go
three or four times before you bail
and if you've never been before expect
it to be uncomfortable
having surgery to get your knees fixed
is uncomfortable
getting shots when you're sick is
uncomfortable
healing is often uncomfortable and when
it comes to feelings and emotions
you just gotta power through
it's not gonna be comfortable and that's
the point
we do hard work and counseling so that
we can breathe at home so that we can
have peace in our souls peace in our
living rooms peace in our bedrooms peace
it's hard to hard work
talking about somebody hurting you and
you're still married to him
talking about how you let your kids down
It's hard talking about how your parents
let you let you down and you still gotta
see them every Christmas or you think
you do it's hard it's hard how your body
failed you and you got sick
how you're you feel like your wife
failed you because you got cancer like
all those things
it's hard
expect it to be challenging okay expect
it to not quote unquote feel good all
the time
in the new modern era expect your
counselor to challenge you if your
counselor I've left counselors and
psychologists before because they
weren't challenging me
they just kept saying how does that make
you feel
my counselor now she challenges me
pushes buttons and I need that I love
that and that's a new wave of therapy
and I'm so grateful that it's it's made
its way into accounting rooms all across
the country you don't want an abusive
person telling you you can't believe
that and that's bullcrap but you do need
somebody pushed on you and challenging
you appropriately okay so that's how to
find a therapist how to find a therapist
listen if you need somebody call
okay how tough you are I don't care what
your job is I don't care how if you've
been before and you got burned call
you are worth being well
so is your family
I love you guys we'll be right back
hey deloney here one of the things I
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible and each person's situation
is unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if I do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as I'd love to I can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
I wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what I would say if you
and I were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book I will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the New Roads of a well life
moving forward go to John deloney.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at John deloney.com
all right we're back hey as we wrap up
today's show we're gonna do something a
little bit different
no song lyrics We will have some song
lyrics and they'll probably have horse
noises in them so everybody just take a
chill but
um in light of that last segment talking
about um how to find a therapist we
reached out to some folks
um who have used better help better help
sponsors the heck out of this show
they've been a great partner and I just
continue to hear great things about
folks who reach out and talk to them but
I wanted to talk to some of you who've
actually used better help okay who've
actually reached out and used them
um I don't want to be recommending a
product that people are coming out and
be like this is awful and so
um we put a lot of time and effort
making sure that these folks are good so
the people that you're going to hear
from are not paid
we didn't pay him a dime okay and not
only are they not making anything
they're being pretty vulnerable they're
getting in front of
um at least 20 or 30 people that's all
that listen to this podcast
um only a few people but they're talking
about their experiences so I want you to
check them out and let this let them
just plant a seed of Courage and the
middle of your chest
if it's time to call somebody that helps
a great place to start all right here we
go roll tape then roll tape
[Music]
the past two years has been a lot for
everyone across the globe and it's been
a lot for me personally so I decided to
use better help for therapy because I
was entering a new season of my life I
have been on better health for about two
weeks now I've experienced job loss
moving across the country when I was
nine months pregnant becoming a
first-time parent to my beautiful
daughter learning how to make new
friends in the midst of the isolation of
the pandemic and losing my cousin due to
mental illness new relationship we were
talking about our future together a new
promotion at work a bunch of new stress
in my life both good and bad that I was
working through and trying to make sure
that I'm using every tool in the toolbox
that I possibly could it was a lot and
so I decided to take up Dr John
deloney's recommendation to use better
help using his promo code and I was
matched with counselors who were able to
talk me through my feelings and what had
recently happened my therapist and I we
communicate many different ways we have
a chat session that we can go back and
forth if I have a story that is going to
be a little too long for texting I can
record myself and send it to her as an
audio file and we also have live
sessions it was a great experience my
therapist that I was matched with she
helped me identify how different traumas
and experiences in my life were
affecting the way I react to things now
she helped me with strategies on how to
approach situations that work better how
not to take work home with me how to
approach conversations with my partner
better I've had a really great
experience with her we have communicated
on all these different topics such as
Parenthood marriage even just some
conversations regarding boundaries with
my with my family that I grew up with we
talked about my marriage my mental
health setting healthier boundaries how
I can make new friends what I should say
yes and no to it was a great experience
it was somebody who's dealt with anxiety
his entire life it was by far the best
counseling experience I've ever had I
can't recom is enough and especially as
you enter different seasons of your life
I think it's a great opportunity to make
sure you're using all the tools you
possibly can I highly encourage everyone
to check it out I think it's been very
enriching for myself and I think it
could be for you all too I would
recommend it to all of my family and
friends to give it a try and I'd highly
recommend it to you